so i want to follow up with you today on
april 1st the first day of april new
month um about what's going on with
radical republican trump is congressman
matt gates matt gates recently appeared
on the tucker carlson show
and announced that he is vindicated and
i was thinking vindic what are you
talking about vindicated you're under a
very serious investigation
in which you may be charged now there
are some who have already sort of moved
on and are assuming that because matt
gates hasn't already been charged he's
not going to be charged and remember the
the
possible crimes and charges have a large
range up to it including child sex
trafficking sex trafficking of a minor
sex trafficking of a minor across state
lines but needless to say for some
reason uh he thinks that he's been um
vindicated and uh here he is talking to
tucker carlson about it a year ago today
365 days that the justice department
leaked a story to the new york times
that it caught our attention immediately
they told the times they were
investigating congressman matt gates
republican of florida
for a very serious crime under aged sex
trafficking right
so gates made an appearance on this show
which turned out to be one of the
weirdest interviews we've ever done he
tried it true he has not been on fox
news since that day
but we did notice since we've been sort
of following it matt gates was never
charged with anything
so how is that the just department calls
new york times and says you're a sex
criminal and then a year later you're
not charged with anything so we thought
it'd be worth inviting congressman matt
gates back on the show thank you for an
update and here he is thank you so much
for coming on
so
you were described in the new york times
by the justice department as a felony
sex criminal have you been charged do
you expect to be charged for felony sex
crimes no this was an operation to
destroy me to harm my family to hinder
my ability to serve the district and the
movement that i represent in congress
and we all know there's a pipeline of
leaks and lies that flow from the
justice department to the mainstream
media the new york times in particular
and that's not even a partisan criticism
of the biden administration that
happened during the trump administration
as well we saw it during the russia hoax
but the most important update the most
important thing that's happened since
our last honorary discussion
someone has been indicted and has pled
guilty to trying to shake down my family
based on this pile of lies and so i'm
not going to allow it to hinder me i'm
going to continue the important work
that i do here in the congress for my
constituents yeah so i'm not going to
ask any questions about your personal
life because it's not my business it's
really simple if you've committed a
crime let them charge you and they
haven't and they've smeared your name
again
your private lice your business whether
you committed a crime or not is
everybody's business and you have it and
there's one ask you one more time
crisply and clearly do you expect to be
charged for the crimes
of which they've accused you
no that would be a travesty i'm innocent
i have maintained my innocence i have
been entirely consistent on this fact
and each and every day the lies about me
unravel and are debunked and the things
i've said and admittedly it's pretty
wild to come on your show and say that
my family's being shaken down for 25
million dollars by some fraudsters some
with connections to the intelligence
community and the department of justice
but in fact someone has pled guilty to
just that so i feel vindicated each and
every day so he's vindicated now notice
a lot of the things that aren't said
there um tucker didn't ask have you been
cleared because the answer is he hasn't
been cleared that's number one it's also
important to mention
none of the claims reported about gates
have been debunked at this point in time
he's just not been charged yet he may
not be charged i'm completely open to
that possibility but tucker didn't ask
have you been cleared because the answer
is no
um
the the thing that he was accused of
doing
uh at one point he claimed he didn't
even know the woman in question we now
have a paper trail where we know that
venmo was actually used to get money
through an intermediary to the woman he
claimed never to have met so that has
not been debunked in fact that's been
confirmed uh and um none of the actual
claims to date have actually been shown
to be untrue also remember just as like
a reminder about the weirdness of this
story
in that weird interview um a year ago i
remember i was on vacation when this
broke and i was on my phone going what
the hell is matt gates talking about
matt gates appeared with tucker in that
weirdest interview we've ever done
and he almost like implicated tucker by
saying you were there with me and had
dinner with one of the people i was with
this was one of the strangest moments
i've ever seen again i only know what
i've read in the new york times i can
say that actually you and i went to
dinner about two years ago your wife was
there and i brought a friend of mine
you'll remember her and she was actually
threatened by the fbi told that if she
wouldn't cop to the fact that somehow i
was involved in some pay for play scheme
uh that she could face trouble and so i
do believe that there are people at the
department of justice who are trying to
smear me uh you know providing for
flights uh and hotel rooms for people
that you're dating who are of legal age
is not a crime uh and i'm just troubled
that the lack of any sort of legitimate
investigation into me would then permute
would then convert into this extortion
attempt
i i don't remember the woman you're
speaking over the context at all
honestly but
oh wouldn't it that if anything could
accurately be described as kafka-esque i
think it would be that so listen yes the
truth is gates has not been charged
um but he has not been cleared
and the assertions gates has made
many of those have been proven to be
false like i don't know this woman
actually you do and you did send her
money supposedly for tuition and books
but you did send her money
and uh the investigation is ongoing but
what a what a bizarre situation
hey this is really interesting
um conspiracy theorist alex jones
appears not only to have completely
turned on donald trump at this point but
seems to be lining up behind ron
desantis now little bits and pieces of
this we've picked up over the last
couple of months there was a story from
a couple of months ago where over
vaccines
uh alex jones seemed to have turned on
donald trump
recently i believe during an interview
with marjorie taylor green alex jones
said something about a desantis green
presidential ticket
but now alex jones straight up is saying
desantis
is better than trump let's take a listen
to this this was from a recent episode
of
infowars
i've gone from liking to santa's to
loving to santas to my instincts have
told me he's good and now he's he's he's
he's got my full backing wow he's the
real deal he's uh better than trump
i'm not trying to pick favorites here i
want trump to get jealous and become
more like desantis we all need to be
more like desantis he's a gentleman he's
smart he's a family man he's a patriot
he's a veteran he is our leader
i mean have you got about who's leading
the fight against the new world war it's
tucker carlson and it's desantis this is
a major i mean for alex jones to declare
someone else his leader i know it's very
easy to laugh all of this stuff off and
go alex jones who's a
it is actually it's it's horrifying
but it actually matt there is a movement
here and when they declare a leader it
actually matters for classy men that are
gentlemen that really care about
everybody that i would say are the best
examples of leadership in america it's
desantis and tucker carlson i'm
obviously the shock trooper that you
know is the kraken you release uh and
and i'm and i'm proud to be that but i
can tell you
that that my job has been to expose this
and bring in the men and bring in the
women uh i i use kind of a john the
baptist analogy god told me that god's
like
alex jones is john the baptist now i
mean look at how sick this is but but
again
if they are getting behind the santas it
actually does matter you are gonna
launch the attack you are gonna
prepare the ground your people are gonna
prepare the ground and then you watch
the leaders will rise uh and and we're
seeing that and all of us are rising
ladies and gentlemen but i just give
credit where it's due it's people like
desantis
and and people like dr carlson i've
almost got rogan super hardcore he's
almost there
i don't know if that's true by the way
that he almost says rogan maybe it is
maybe it isn't or and then he kind of
goes back a little uh but uh
i just got to spend more time with him i
love joe we can hang anytime i want him
to call him yeah let's go get dinner i
gotta hang out sometimes we hang like
twice a week i just you know it's just
joe is really such a sweetheart that if
the the but he doesn't want to be in the
middle of the fight not because he's a
coward he's almost embarrassed to be
that deep in the fight and it's just
okay so
alex jones here making it clear that
desantis is their leader interestingly
enough when you look at the money line
when you because you
you one of the great things about
america great or terrible you can bet on
anything you want and people bet on who
is the republican nominee going to be
and it has not shifted significantly if
you go to predict.org you can look at
the betting markets on a lot of these
different questions and the question who
will win the 2024 republican nomination
it's pretty steady but desantis is very
close to trump trump about 38 cents of
every dollar is being bet on trump will
be the nominee and 29 cents of every
dollar is being bet on ron desantis is
going to be the nominee so
this is let's put it this way
this margin for trump right now in terms
of who people believe will be the
nominee for the republicans in 2024
this is one scandal away from reversing
if
trump has some major scandal that's
really embarrassing among the
republicans and of course his most
devoted followers don't care but if it's
something that
people who are still slightly connected
to reality are are turned off by
that nine point that you know that's a
four and a half point swing right in the
sense that if trump loses four and a
half and desantis gains four and a half
you've got a tie for the republican
nomination
those are precarious numbers for donald
trump given that we are two and a half
roughly years out from the 2024 election
so it's a race to the bottom believe me
but it's a race to the bottom that we
care about because the consequences are
unimaginably huge huge as i talked about
earlier republicans winning elections in
the next two election cycles
imperils american democracy
and so that's why we care
whether alex jones is abandoning trump
or not and he does indeed seem to be let
me know your thoughts let me know your
thoughts about who you believe will be
the republican nominee if it's something
you're already thinking about you can
find me on twitter at deepakman it is
april 1st and it is great to be here and
we've got a packed program for you
coming up today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported program you can sign
up and get a membership at
joinpakman.com you can also now gift
memberships if you have one
but you want to give one to someone else
you can check the this is a gift box in
the sign up process and if you don't
have anyone to give a membership to
we have 220 people who have requested
free memberships we will be glad
to give you uh to give them one of the
memberships that you gift you can do it
all
at joinpackman.com
let's hear from people in the audience
we do these calls once a week via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and it is a great thing it's a
shame we can't do it more i would say
much to the chagrin of many in our
audience
let's start today
oh i don't know
let's go to canada let's start with
jason from toronto
hey dave how you doing i'm doing well
thank you for asking uh thanks for
taking my call again i actually spoke to
you recently uh
about uh putin and uh
russia and um
the impact that that would have uh with
trump in power so thanks for taking my
call again uh just a quick question not
really political or politics related but
more just a personal question what do
you enjoy most about what you do
honestly it's that i i it's not really a
real job in the sense of like i don't
have an annoying boss or have to go
anywhere or anything like that just the
autonomy i would say
awesome um
i know that you've been doing this for a
while now how many how many years have
you been had your show i think about 80
years now
that's awesome well anyways thanks for
taking my call it was just a simple
question right things are good in canada
yeah things are things are good we still
have uh a little bit of snow here in
southern ontario
um which is really annoying but i'll be
in the states in a couple weeks so i'm
kind of excited to go somewhere warmer
is ontario hostile to poutine because
it's just too french
uh no it's just less prevalent around
here um but people embrace the food just
as they would in montreal or
across canada so that's good news i'm
i'm uh pleased by that at least
for sure all right thank you for the
call great to talk to you
take care all right there is jason
from toronto what a day
let's go uh we're kind of going around
the world a little bit uh today let's go
to is it
sauger
from melbourne australia
uh hey david it's melbourne australia
okay so
sagar beautiful welcome
yeah um so two quick questions uh number
one there was a book that came out
recently this week
it was called uh a hundred percent
democracy the case for universal voting
as well as two washington op-ed pieces i
was just curious because i watched one
of your videos from seven years ago
and uh you seemed in favor of universal
voting
but you were more you weren't really
strong in your conviction i do wonder
seven years later and the and seeing the
advent of the trump administration
and voting suppression
have you become stronger in your
conviction for the case for universal
voting now just to be clear do you mean
mandatory voting
uh yes oh yeah here's the thing i'm i'm
not i'm not big i'm big on everybody
voting but i'm not so big on mandatory
voting i i respect the idea
that opting out of the of participating
is a valid expression of of politics
what i disagree with is people who don't
vote because of apathy people who just
don't pay attention people who don't
care so for me it's not about force
everybody to vote and in fact if you do
that
that that might that could potentially
be a disaster i'm more about i want to
work towards a system or a framework
where everybody wants to vote i want
people to want to vote rather than to
force people to vote does that make
sense
no yeah i completely understand because
i was also the similar opinion because
i'm origin from canada and i moved to
australia about eight years ago so i was
with you on the whole like i want to
just make it as easy as possible for
people to vote
but the thing i've noticed because
australia does have mandatory voting and
as now as a citizen i see that there's a
very strong case for it because uh
first of all the elections here are held
on saturdays
so it's pretty easy to vote already
and so really the only thing that could
come in hand is is voter apathy and my
very strong belief i believe voter
apathy is corrosive to democracy agree
is extremely close to democracy and as
well as the election days here are an
event so if you head to a polling booth
you're going to have a sausage you're
going to have drinks it's going to be
you're going to have time to to talk
with the
uh uh representatives from the from the
from the parties sure and it's become it
becomes this cherished institution and i
do believe and also the in addition to
the whole mandatory thing it's a 50 fine
here and for the most part two-thirds of
those fines get waived
and so for the most part there isn't
much of a penalty but it's just it's
just this thing that has become
ingrained in australian society
of voting and it's like and it's when
you look at the results it's 96 percent
turnout 95 turnout very high turnout and
it's really and again in my very strong
opinion uh if you want to maintain a
democracy
voting needs to be a civil duty similar
to you know how taxes is paying your
taxes as a civil duty i believe that
voting should be just as strong all
right well you've made a very strong
case for it and i'm willing to listen to
arguments uh in in that direction thank
you for the uh for the phone call
thank you so much david have a nice one
very powerful call i must say extremely
well prepared that's really the
that is actually
the call everybody should aspire to
couple minutes long
polite
good audio
right to the topic prepared beautiful
beautifully done
let's go next to spencer from california
spencer go
hey david thanks for taking my call
so
i think one thing that we encourage is
or at least you encourage on your show
is teaching media literacy and viewing
it as something that has a positive
impact in terms of educating people yes
i was reading an article which says that
part of the way we teach media literacy
is telling readers to critically think
about how information is constructed
who's paying for it
and what's being left out
and as a result this leads to some level
of mistrust and maybe even hostility
towards news sources
the way that we learn it and maybe this
even drives some
radicalization
so
what's the right way to develop media
literacy skills while trying to prevent
this effect of causing people to have
this predisposition that media is not to
be trusted you know i thought that the
caller before you was one of the best
calls we've had
this may
be in contention for one of the best
calls this is a perfectly constructed
question so your question is a brilliant
one which is
if one has not been
exposed
to
the basic
skepticism that we should bring to any
messages we receive and this means a
sign on the outside of a building a tv
commercial a news report
if your first exposure to this type of
critical thinking
is in media literacy
you might incorrectly
develop a hostility towards media
because you've never thought about this
framework before and all of a sudden
you're being told we've got to apply it
specifically to media you're a hundred
percent right and so
what we need to do is
that framework of how to think about
things how to know why we believe the
things we believe
it has to be introduced earlier before
the context is even media literacy and
here's what i mean
if two years before
media literacy becomes a topic you were
generally instructed on
how to evaluate whether something should
be believed or not and it's applied to
everything it's applied to the things
your classmates say it's applied to all
sorts of phenomena why why do you
believe how do you know what your age is
how old how old are we kids we're seven
how do you know that
do you remember each of the seven years
well no it's because our parents told us
okay and how do you even right so if you
first develop that as a general
framework for evaluating why we believe
the things we believe
once it's applied to media it shouldn't
generate that sort of distrust and
you're a hundred percent correct
yeah i think that makes a lot of sense
uh and then one more question sure if
possible it's gonna be i mean you know
you may want to go out on top but but
let's see this i don't know if the next
question could possibly live up to the
first one
sure so maybe on a sort of related issue
how do you respond to friends and people
who are simply misinformed but they're
not too far removed from reality in
their beliefs
so for instance maybe someone who thinks
that biden is largely responsible for
gas prices they might have just heard
that somewhere and blindly repeated it
yeah without thinking or checking for
themselves
um but in essence what i'm asking is
what's the best way to confront these
people and tell them that they're wrong
without seeming too argumentative or
just flat out telling them that they're
incorrect oh i mean that that one's very
easy particularly if it's people you
generally get along with you would say
oh now that's interesting biden's
responsible for the high gas prices
tell me more about that what what did
biden do to raise gas prices and
almost certainly they're already going
to go nowhere and then i would say oh
well because you know gas prices are up
in every country
does biden affect gas prices in every
country and if so how i mean that i
would just diffuse that with some very
light questions
right yeah yeah i was thinking that was
the approach to go also
all right excellent phone call i
congratulate you
thanks for taking my call david all
right very good guys i'm almost scared
to take the next call
because it's going to be very hard to
live up to some of these
let's go to our old friend brody from
dallas uh brody please don't torpedo
today's session of calls
i'm gonna do my best david how's it
going man going well
awesome hey so um we're fighting the
good fight out here in texas we recently
had a huge fiasco in the primary
elections
we had a huge disparity we had about 850
democratic primary voters had their
mail-in ballots rejected and less than
10
republican primary voters had their
ballots rejected
one of the things we've
struggled with here is getting help from
dc and i know that there's talk about
joe manchin
possibly carving out some things for
different voting rights legislation what
i wanted to know is what do you see as
the most viable path
for states like texas to have protection
from dc or do you believe that it's just
going to have to come from all the state
legislatures
and as a follow-up what would you like
to see happen
so the i don't i don't know
exactly what you're referring to in
texas so without knowing the dynamics of
it it's very hard to say specifically
what could address that so just with
that as a kind of disclaimer
i would love to see a new voting rights
act that restricts the things that
states can do
and allows for federal oversight i think
many states you know they with the
a couple years ago
states were sort of released from their
requirements to pre-clear changes i
think we need to be adding more
requirements in terms of changes that
states want to make that would be the
ideal thing i don't know that that's
going to happen and so of course it
would be great if states did legislation
on voting rights within their own states
but the problem is republican-controlled
states don't really have any interest in
doing that so it's a very tough
situation i don't know what the answer
is
then as a personal question
would you be willing like let's say
would you compromise at all if uh let's
say
republicans in the gop in the senate
particularly wanted to enact something
would you as a progressive and just you
personally be willing to acquiesce or
agree
to maybe
including voter id
being required as a part of that so long
as it doesn't disenfranchise people
or do you believe that voting id is
something that should be non-negotiable
from the democrat and the progressive
side of things so
two-part answer and these are really you
know you know these are big topics right
so there's a lot of different
considerations
i am
very skeptical of voter id because it is
a transparently bad faith way for
republicans to disenfranchise people so
that's why i have such a problem with
voter id as proposed and implemented
that being said if there was a voting
rights package that did significant good
things and codified them into law
i'd be open to negotiating on voter id
provided i was satisfied that there
really is
you know it you it can't cost money to
get the documents you need to get the
voter id it can't require rural poor
people to drive to the state capitol in
order to get the documents they need to
get the vote ready like if i was really
satisfied that all of those things were
dealt with i'd be willing to negotiate
on voter id as part of a bigger voting
rights package the problem is in
practice we know it's just a bad faith
way to purge people from voter rolls and
prevent people from voting
absolutely well hey i'm glad to have
talked with you and i hope i lived up at
least moderately or mildly to the
expectations and it's good to speak to
you again and please encourage all your
voters like you always do to register
and go out and vote everyone must vote
brody thank you so much for the call
let's take a quick break but we're going
right back to the phones in a moment so
if you still want to talk to me after
hearing all of these calls if you still
want to talk to me just hang on
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow right let's go back to
the phones where so many people want to
chat
let's start with jordan from minnesota
jordan you're on the air
jordan from minnesota you're on the air
oh
not a great start not a great start here
uh i guess no jordan from minnesota
let's try instead harry from columbus
ohio
david can you hear me yes i can
thank you so much for taking my call
firstly i wanted to
raise a quibble with how you pronounce
um a certain set of words
now whenever you are using the word
historic i noticed that you will say a
or am historic
which
i have no understanding of why you would
say and historic could you care to
explain that yeah
this is a this is a topic of big debate
among the uh grammar uh nazis and
pronunciation experts
there are certain you know typically the
rule would be that if the word starts
with a vowel
it would be an and if the word starts
with a consonant it would be a so a cat
versus an apple the thing about real
quickly
just before we want so i know you're
talking about and if we use the word
let's say hour
like
the hour of the day we would say oh it
took an hour to get there because we
pronounced the word hour with a silent h
yes correct yes the word historic we do
not have a silent h we have a very hard
h well the thing about batteries and i
apologize uh in order to
fight back against your interruption i
am now going to interrupt
the thing about historic is there are
some words where when it's pronounced in
isolation
they have a very clear consonant sound
like if i just say
historic but historic has a relatively
soft h when in context and that is why
my understanding is that it is
acceptable to say
and historic and you're kind of running
it together
if that is how you see it i i can't
disagree with it we'll just have to
agree to disagree on that that's fair um
secondly real quickly and i wanted to
get into this how do you feel about
that now that jd vance has completely
you know kind of fallen off the wagon a
bit in my opinion yeah how do you feel
about josh mandel and gibbons with the
with the pre-note that you know mandel
ran against um senator
uh what's his what's his name
in 2012 he ran against the current
democratic senator um
from ohio
jared brown
listen i i think that they're all toxic
i think that all of those republican
primary candidates are all completely
toxic now you're completely right like
listen a couple years ago i bought the
book hillbilly elegy everybody said
listen this book this is a good story
of growing up in the rural poor white
midwest and south you'll understand
conservatism you should really read this
book and i read j.d vance's book
and first of all i mean his grandma as
he writes in the book was like a kennedy
democrat so it's not even like it wasn't
even that great of an expose about
conservatism because his family was
actually sort of liberal but anyway i
was like okay this is like a thinking
guy
and he has gone completely off the rails
pro trump or at least hesitating to
criticize trump and just bottom of the
barrel
red meat he's absolutely i'm embarrassed
that i thought he was mildly reasonable
after reading the book
yeah i can see where that perspective
came from and a lot of people still hold
that perspective without the knowledge
of what he said otherwise now real quick
before i drop mandel i think if mandel
starts the search i don't think trump
will throw his hat in the ring i think
he'll see that mandel lost in 2012 he's
a loser quote unquote yep um i expect
mike gibbons to really start to pull
ahead if trump you know nominates or you
know
trump has been extremely extremely
scared to put his voice like into this
race yeah i think he may just be waiting
to see how it shakes out before he does
when's the primary there
the primary is may 3rd but as you may or
may not have heard we've had a lot of
issues regarding
uh congressional maps lots of
time in the supreme court of ohio
and as of yesterday
ohio aclu is suing the the gop map
makers so it's it's still got a lot of
story left to play out here in ohio
thanks for taking call david hey real
quick are you talking through a voice
modulator or through some kind of metal
screen
i am using a bluetooth headset that is
probably not the optimal way of talking
i'll try to get on a better microphone
next time we speak thank you for
beautiful all right thank you so much i
appreciate the call
wow what a phone call guys it is really
something else today
let's go next to kevin from uh virginia
kevin from virginia you're on the air
hello david hello
i realize this is kind of
old news at this point but i've been
trying to call in the last couple of
weeks i want to talk about uh permanent
daylight saving time okay
i am on on the side of permanent
standard time
i could go on a diatribe of i i
personally think it's better but i think
my best argument on the subjects is more
of a historical one
so my framing of this issue is
if if we are going to go to permanent
daylight saving time what we're really
doing is we're changing our time zones
by one time zone
and you're kind of saying
if you want to go to permanent daylight
saving time you're saying we got it
wrong
when we established
the time zones in the late 1800s or you
think society has changed fundamentally
in that last 150 or so years
that we all benefit from shifting our
schedules by
one hour sure and i just don't think
that's i don't think that's accurate i
think
there was a lot of thought put into the
time zones when they were established
and it lined up with
solar time that we used for
millennia
i don't think we should change that
so listen i think that actually society
has changed dramatically since the time
zones were established by virtue of
completely ubiquitous electricity and
artificial lighting i think i think that
it has changed now that's not reason
alone to say let's do permanent daylight
saving now i lean towards permanent
daylight saving you know why because i
don't get up early enough to care about
it being dark in the morning and i get a
lot of benefit from it being light out
an additional hour in winter in the
northeast
in middle of december it's it's ugly
it's depressing what goes on in the
northeast now that being said
i am sensitive to the fact that you know
if you look at the western edge of
certain time zones like for example if
you look at columbus ohio is an
interesting place
in columbus ohio they're on the western
edge of the eastern time zone
if we were to do permanent daylight
saving time if i understand correctly in
december sunrise would be something like
8 20 in columbus i looked it up at one
point i don't exactly remember i agree
that that's kind of complicated that's
not so good so another idea i heard was
split the difference make a 30 minute
adjustment and make that permanent the
problem is that then the difference
between our time zones and those in
other parts of the world are going to be
you know six and a half hours eight and
a half hours which is just very
complicated so i don't know that there's
a perfect solution
i hate what we do now and i lean towards
permanent daylight saving time
i also hate what we do now yeah um i
personally i think we need to be taking
a hard look at
schedule of the business day the
schedule of schools you know there's
been a lot written about
school starting too early and the health
impacts that has on our children i think
absolutely
going with permanent daylight saving
time we're kind of sidestepping
the real issue but yeah
also which is there are other countries
where it's much much more typical that
the business and work day starts at
either 9 30 or 10 and goes till more
like six or seven and then like in a lot
of places in europe you leave work at
seven
and then you know you go right to drinks
and then a later dinner like when i was
in spain now spain maintains the siesta
for a lot of workers
you open the store at ten and then
you're off from one to three and then
you're open from three to seven and at
seven you go for a drink and at 9 30 you
have dinner and it's just a totally
different lifestyle now culturally i
don't know that that'll work in the u.s
but there's many other configurations of
the daily schedule that could work
well i appreciate you talking to me
about this i'll be curious to see if if
it does get enacted permanently yeah you
still like it after your first winter
going through it because right now
we know what standard time is like in
the winter and we have some issues with
that but
unless we can remember back to 1974 we
don't really know what the warnings are
like in a winter with dst and i think
people are i'll sleep through it so i
just won't know i mean i'll be fine
all right all right kevin thank you uh i
i i do care about that topic actually i
find it pretty pretty interesting
okay let's go next to god i always
struggle with this um alisa medua from
dallas did i get it right this time oh
honestly
i i'm giving you an a plus for that
because i could tell that you've been
putting in the practice and i really do
appreciate it my pleasure do you do most
people just call you oh
uh yeah because i mean they have the
same issue with butchering my name okay
so i mean it's because like my parents
are from nigeria yeah i was born here so
you'd have to blame my mom for that fair
well let's we'll do that on a different
episode
yeah so uh again thank you so much for
taking my uh call uh today i wanted to
talk about something different and um
it's in regards to um you know food and
i mean i know it's not a very attractive
you know topic topic to be talking about
given how we're talking about ukraine
trump and you know biden but i feel like
food is a big you know issue uh they're
not a big issue but like obesity in
general uh in the united states is
obviously
you know a very concerning issue that
not enough people are talking about
and i feel like you know most of it
stems from you know our poor you know
guidance and education
on food in general like a good example
of this is the first food pyramid that
came out in like i think the 80s for the
united states where
you know the very bottom of the food
pyramid said that we should have six to
11 servings of bread pasta
but like less servings of you know
vegetables and fruit i mean i have no
idea how that makes sense whatsoever but
i also know that you know unfortunately
big food aka the food lobby you know
they were you know pressuring you know
the usda you know a lot uh in terms of
you know making sure that they would be
able to like push their products so
um i know i kind of went all over the
place with this but i guess my question
is what do you think that like we could
do
you um you know combat this issue with
you know
um obesity and um
i guess you know
yeah like what do you think that we
could do it's such a big topic i mean
there's so many issues here and
oh man and it also gets very
touchy politically to talk about obesity
um one of the there's a bunch of
different things here first of all of
course there's an educational aspect to
it where a lot of people have been given
bad information or no information about
uh you know the what it actually means
to eat like a healthy balanced diet
number two you look at
marketing and the way that marketing
uh for food products not for ingredients
for food products because that's what
they are
steers people towards unhealthy food i
mean most of the food that's marketed is
not healthy because just basic
ingredients
don't really need marketing i mean okay
like you'll see like avocados in general
advertised or sometimes like milk
generally but for the most part the
advertising is for
finished food products you then see the
financial incentive where you know just
growing corn it's like okay
it's just corn and that's what it is but
if you can separate corn into 10
different products and then use them as
additives and
you can generate more profit
but you're also giving people extremely
processed items
habits that are set by parents for young
kids and the age at which you know kids
start having juice and soda and candy
and this type of thing there's so many
different things here that it is just a
massive problem to get our head around
and there's no there's no easy solution
at this point
yeah i totally understand and um one
book that i've been like you know
looking into reading uh it's called food
politics i'm not sure if you're familiar
with the book but
i'm probably going to pick up the book
sometime soon to get a better
understanding of that but um
yeah thank you so much for taking my
call and really quick special shout out
to david pepper
really good interview that you did with
him i actually know him um not like
super personally but i've met him on
campus at the university of cincinnati
so i was like really shocked to see you
like david and david interviewing each
other so uh again thank you so much for
everything that you do and again good
interview and i hope to talk to you soon
man all right sounds good thanks for the
call always great to hear from oh
let's talk to
brian from eastern shore maryland not a
place i've heard of before brian
brian you're on the air you've got to
unmute in order to talk to me though
oh boy
that's too bad things were going so well
they really were
uh i guess no no brian there let's go to
southcat from virginia southcat you're
on the air
uh hello david uh
uh thanks for taking my call i actually
popped on to listen but um
yeah i will ask you
i'll bring something up that's been on
my mind
and by the way are you are you
originally from virginia
no i'm i'm actually from australia oh
okay that makes sense
so
yeah um
something came up in my mind recently
was
how much it actually costs to have a
child in the u.s
um whether you're
insured or not insured or anything like
that
if you're not insured
and this is a basic right to have a
child
you know um
and i think
there's very few opportunities to have a
child for free this is reproduction
i'm not sure if you know anything more
about that but then you've also got the
issue of the abortion issue that's going
on
um and i find i've just really found it
quite shocking that it can cost it i
mean if you've got a private room you've
got the money
so it
all comes down to money
is that anything you've thought about
yeah i mean
it's this way with a lot of different
things and depending on you know what
you consider a right you would focus in
on different aspects when i had my
random appendectomy i believe the
sticker price was 40 000 i was at the
hospital in total i think about
uh
eight hours i think and it was you know
about 40 grand from what i've read that
the sticker price on on most
deliveries can approach a hundred
thousand dollars and if there's
complications you know you could be
talking about half a million every day
in the in the nicu is just outrageous
yeah i mean this is a bigger problem
it's a systemic problem that relates to
the health care system but you're 100
correct
yeah i just think
i mean i don't understand that there's
huge problems with the health care
system but
having a baby you know
uh is
it's it's just
struck me as crazy yeah it costs i mean
at least maybe they could
i mean listen it's crazy but there's a
lot of other equally crazy things in the
united states so i don't disagree with
you it's just you know i'm sort of used
to it i guess
yeah i i guess so yeah um anyway thanks
for taking my call all right southcat
from virginia originally
from australia folks i think we did it
despite the two dropped calls one of the
best
series of calls ever on the show we will
take a break and be back with much much
more after this
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
let's get right into this week's world
famous mailbag if you have a message for
me hopefully substantive hopefully
not containing slurs you can email info
davidpakman.com and many of you do
and we review a handful or so of the
couple handfuls i guess depends on the
size of your hand a handful of those
emails every single week starting
sometimes with people who don't like me
dakota wrote in with the subject you're
a village idiot now almost a requirement
is that you use the wrong form of your
versus you are and indeed that's what
dakota does
you're a village idiot my
a village idiot okay you spit on all the
graves of all the fine people who have
fought for this country and die for your
lazy ass
anybody know what they're talking about
you piss on the graves of all the fine
people who have gave their lives for
you can say the s
and lies you spume
you s on the lives of the family members
who have given their sons and daughters
so you slime ball can lie like you do
you are garbage
and an effing waste of sperm
please go back to school and get an
education and maybe you can get a job
on cnn
you're
a loser that's y-o-u-r
i think this is sort of like a
presented
without comment type of scenario
let's move on
this one almost
just as bad jeremy wrote in
with the subject commie idiot
this email
you have to describe them if case people
are listening written in all capital
letters
jeremy writing
hey commie genius if there's global
warning
why is it so cold here in texas more
like global cooling
were sick of t
fake news media and you're dumb
the only medi we trust now is oan and
newsmax
i hope you freeze to death spelled like
the great drummer josh friese not freeze
i hope you freeze to death with your
global warming and covet hoax
ps you're gay y-o-u-r you're gay
pps trump won by a landslide he's still
my president and yours takami just wait
till march 4 you and the other commies
will be arrested the military is taking
cone troll and trump is in charge
education
critical thinking
mental health treatment
media literacy
many deficits in this country
exposed
by the mailbag all right let's get into
more substance
substantive stuff felix wrote in saying
trump guilty of numerous felonies why
not prosecuted it's a fair question
dear david sir i genuinely don't
understand it trump seems to be guilty
of numerous felonies why isn't he
prosecuted why not convicted why is
there obviously no interest in doing so
are there serious consequences for the
person who would have the power to do it
this person could go down in the history
books wouldn't it also be something the
democrats could use well in the election
campaign i genuinely don't get it um
yeah these are these are all fair
questions and what we learned last week
is that the prosecutors investigating
trump in manhattan believed he had
indeed committed multiple provable
felonies and resigned so did mark
pomerance the prosecutor resigned
because he
thought it clear
that there was no actual plan to
prosecute trump he said we've done the
investigation
we have the evidence the evidence is
solid enough we could prove this stuff
in court but there's no interest in
prosecuting and as i've said before
there's big hesitation to be the first
to prosecute i believe if you saw one
prosecution of trump that you would see
many and what they're afraid of
i don't know at the end of the day
as many of you know we did start
publishing the david pakman show clips
to the right wing platform rumble
langdon wrote in about rumble and saying
it's not so much free speech hey david
when i saw you joined rumble i figured i
would join as well and test their claims
of being immune to cancer culture and
100 free speech as you probably know
videos and comments are rated by the
number of rumbles received you can rate
a video or comment with a positive or a
negative rumble so for example if a
comment gets four positives and six
negatives your net rumble is minus
when you get into the negative
your comment is automatically hidden and
you are not allowed to reply to any
replies to your original comment this is
not a shock
this is not a shock and there is no i
mean listen we all know that that
we're a free if a platform markets
itself as being a free speech platform
it's already kind of weird you know when
i think of
platforms i think about their
functionality and utility youtube
the biggest video sharing site in the
world oh it's about sharing videos
that's what it's about
um uh tiktok it is a rapidly growing
vertical format short form video content
oh okay that's what it's about
when someone says this is a free speech
platform
it's almost not even really a meaningful
mission or description and uh you should
anytime you hear that
you should at least be wondering what
the hell are they talking about
uh let's see mike wrote in
about my appearance on the right wing
michael knowles show saying dear david
pakman coming from a conservative
perspective i heard you on the michael
knowles show this morning and wanted to
thank you for coming across the aisle to
have such a civil conversation about
such polarizing issues i was extremely
impressed in the way you engaged him i
meandered over to your site and again
was quite impressed i'm looking forward
to exploring more of your content i hope
other daily wire followers are as
appreciative of your willingness to
debate these topics something i find
less and less of these days best of luck
yeah i actually did get three
very nice emails from people who caught
my daily wire appearance here's another
one kyle hey really enjoyed your
perspective while you were on the
michael knowles show i don't agree with
everything he said i don't agree with
everything he says but finding different
opinions where crap is not shoved down
our neck
without a moment to hear a counter
opinion is not always easy to find i
appreciate you having a conversation
with them and keeping them honest i
appreciated your insistence be heard so
i could understand your perspective
better even if it challenged my own
views
this is this is great this is great to
see unfortunately the vast majority of
the messages i got were horribly
anti-semitic and and just slurs and
attacks
but
i did get three nice messages
um from that appearance
carrie rhoden
carrie says hey david love your show my
whole family watches together every
night miss you on weekends not sure if
you've covered this but it would be
interesting to delve into the psychology
behind why some people believe in
conspiracy theories there must be a
certain personality type that has the
tendency to be drawn into conspiracy
over truth and facts have a great day it
is an interesting topic
we've studied it extensively and i've
done a number of interviews and at the
end of the day
one of the in talking with a person
you'll sometimes
learn that they don't like uncertainty
and not liking uncertainty often goes
hand in hand with being susceptible to
conspiratorial thinking and the
underlying kind of idea
is
when terrible things happen seemingly
that are random
that can be really tough for people
who want to believe everything is
certain everything is planned everything
is predictable and happens for a reason
and so it starts to become preferable to
them to believe instead of wow that was
a random bombing i could have been there
or my loved ones could have been anybody
could have been there that's crazy
completely unpredictable
instead it's more comforting in a way to
know
there's not random bad stuff that was a
planned event it was a false flag it was
whatever
that
idea or that feeling
is common to a lot of conspiratorial
thinking not all and there's much more
to it but that is something we've
explored and very much worthwhile
last one today is from judy i'm sorry
it's from joseph
and it's about the katanji brown jackson
hearings and it makes no sense the
subject line is
judy demeaning yourself
i don't know what that means anyway it
says david
when you just lie
and act like justices barrett and
kavanaugh were not qualified for the
supreme court based on their resume
you just demean yourself
both were highly qualified just as
katanji brown jackson is when you feel
the need to lie
and ignore reality you undermine
everything you say
i never said
barrett and kavanaugh
were unqualified
what i said were two things and this is
where please react to the things i say
not the things you heard or want me to
have said what i pointed out was if you
look at her experience across eight
different areas of
law and judging
judge jackson is more qualified
than all nine currently on the court
that's one thing i said and i believe
that that's true if you look at her
experience not only as a federal judge
but on a sentencing commission and you
look at all those things she has more
types of experience than any of the nine
currently on the court do
in addition i said
the idea
that kavanaugh and barrett could be
qualified and jackson isn't is laughable
so i never said kavanaugh wasn't
qualified
i never said barrett wasn't qualified
what i said is it's cartoony
to suggest
kavanaugh and barrett might be qualified
but jackson is not
that doesn't make any sense so joseph
critical listening
critical listening very very important
skill to learn so we used to call it
active listening in school
let's learn it we have a great bonus
show for you today sign up at join
pacman.com to get access
we will be a little bit of a different
schedule going on next week but i will
tell you about it
soon but don't miss today's bonus show